M it's
God it's
god let's give everybody a hand for
y'all coming out here today man thank
you I might be a
politician all right all right let's get
this show on the
road all right turn on your mics test it
test it test it testing 1 2 3 T Test
there we go we good to go all right who
going uh want to introduce first JP it's
up to you I mean I guess you're the
guest so you can go first all right
since I'm the guest all right you know
hospitalities you know so first of all I
want to thank uh Captain Cesar for
agreeing to the discussion man uh I
appreciate it man and bringing everybody
through um so I'm praying that this goes
well and it's fruitful I pray that uh
the seeds are planted and um and that
everyone learns and everyone has a good
time here we're going to have a good
time my name is Avery uh channel is God
logic apologetics we are discussing
whether or not Jesus Is God and
obviously I hold the position that Jesus
is God he's the Divine Son of God who
came into the flesh he pre-existed
before his human birth and existed
eternally with the father and the spirit
with uh Eternal fellowship and eternal
communion and I believe that the
scripture is very very clear on that and
we're going to discuss that today so if
you guys want to find me it's God logic
apologetics God logic G on Instagram and
on Facebook and that's where you guys
can hit me up if you guys have questions
or want to see anything all right that's
my
intro my turn now um I do want to
appreciate also God Logic for uh coming
out here setting up I want to thank all
the people that came out here this is um
a good opportunity for us to have a
public discussion on the subject of
Jesus Is God make no mistake about it
Jesus is not God and even in terms where
people are called Gods there a no
reference or at any time of being the
most high God you have a God you have a
son and if the son has a God and he
can't be God so I hope we not going to
get into semantics of the word God and
just just stick right to the subject of
is Jesus God as Christian teach it
believing that he is God so we'll use
Christ words we'll use the scriptures
I'm looking forward to having a um well
healthy debate on this subject and um I
mainly deal with scriptures I'm not a
isog what what ises ex whichever words
those are whichever one of those words
are I also don't talk when people
talking um I like like to point that out
I didn't talk in his intro but I don't
do none of that when um when I'm talking
I mean it's a skill it's a gift so I
don't do none of that but we will be
pointing out through the Bible if you
pull out anything outside of the Bible
we would have to say that they're not
following the Bible because the Bible
has to be our foundation the scripture
say let God be true and every man a liar
so if the scripture doesn't reference
him as being God as the most high god um
then I wouldn't take that term I rather
believe what Christ said in Christ said
he's the son of God so that's my
position and I'm ready to rock and roll
all right let's get ready to rumble
folks all right so um I guess to kick
this off um I would ask if you believe
that the sun is a created being yeah the
sun has a creation point the sun is the
first creation of God okay and then
through that sun that's how you get
everything else that's Colossians 1:5
okay so you're taking firstborn when it
says he's the firstborn of all creation
you're taking that literal to mean that
he is the first thing that the most high
ever created that's the only thing the
most high put his hands on is Christ
okay so the Most High created Christ and
then gave Christ the ability to create
you know the Angels the principalities
the people the planet the Earth he's the
mouth or word of God at that point okay
but he would be subordinate so in the
pecking order you would have the Father
the Son the son is subordinate to the
father okay so it would be like that so
in in Colossians 1 when it continues to
say like why Paul called him the
firstborn right he says he's the image
of the invisible God the firstborn of
all creation for by him all things were
created in heaven on Earth dominions
Powers principalities rulers all things
were created through him and for him so
how can he be part of creation if he
himself created all things I didn't you
asked the question that you asked was
not is um the question that you asked
was was he created yeah and that's facts
is the first
born God is not born God is there is no
born point for God but we do have a born
Point based on even that scripture that
you just said that he's born and then
when you keep reading I think in verse
19 in Colossians 1 it said it please the
father that in him should all fullness
dwell so even in the term father son
somebody had to be created and it ain't
the father so that even him being a son
means he's created okay so I I I would
disagree with that and here's why
because if we're taking like what the
text says right it says that for by him
all things were created if you're saying
that Jesus was created by the father
then that would contradict when it says
he created all things and then all
things were created through him I I
guess I I would ask did the father if so
all things were created through the son
was the son also then created through
himself that's kind of like a illogical
question because then you would be
saying that Jes I'm assuming because you
take the position of Jesus as God you
can't fathom that Christ could have a
starting point if it says if it please
the father in him all fullness dwell who
authorize Christ to do everything it's
it's the father's author author so did
CH did the father exist without Christ
or before Christ no can you prove that
yeah with the scripture here that's what
that's why I asked if all things were
created through him right
weird no look look you're saying that
he's a he's the first thing that the
father created if that's correct then
you have to say that through the son
Jesus was created cuz it says all things
were created through him no that's
that's not what that text mean that like
again it's illogical that's not what
that text mean because at some point
there was the father by himself where
does it say that it doesn't say that
there in that verse when it says um
Christ is the beginning of creation that
means something is creating the
beginning and that's the most high
creating Christ okay and then from there
I mean you want to read it would it be
better to read it might help you cuz I
think you I think you foggy right now no
no I'm not the foggy one I think no
definitely not because it says if it
says in it pleased the father that in
him that mean the father did something
for a son we agree right yes so if you
have a child right you exist before the
child right well that's that's me I'm a
human but it is a fatherson relationship
there's no woman there so it's it's a
metaphor right well well is the father
son metaphor I I would not say that it's
metaphoric you know I I would say that
why would you say because it's a real
it's a real relationship that I a say
the relationship I'm talking about the
terminology of father son in a normal
environment it's a man woman and child
excuse me man and woman that makes a
child like Exodus 4:22 says Israel is my
son even my first born that's not
literal
it's a metaphor for a relationship right
so now you have a father and a son
that's a metaphor of a relationship so a
father exists before a son is there okay
that's common sense I ask you this let
me ask you this was the father always
the father Yes okay are you I would say
the most high always is yeah right so
he's always been the father he's always
been has he always been the father well
he was the father once Christ is there
that's why I'm saying it so so at one
point he was not the father he became I
would never say that he's not the father
all right that's what I'm asking so was
there at any point in all of history of
you know of all eternity that God was
not the father no okay so because the
father is just that's why I said it's
not a literal connection the father is
the father of all things got it like
Christ can be or Abraham is like called
the father of our faith faith is not a
child either it's a right so it's a
metaphor so him being a father is always
being a father on this subject though he
was Christ's father and he created
Christ and then gave Christ the ability
to do the things that he did he also
took things from Christ okay like when
Christ ask the father to give him his
glory back yeah because that's a father
separate from himself so God can't
unless unless Christ talking to himself
let's talk about this fatherhood okay so
the implications of the example that you
gave you said in every example when
there's a you know there's father
there's there's woman and then there's
the son you're saying in every example
the father always exists before the son
does and so I'm saying in that layout
you have a problem with your theology
because that's not my theology well well
if you're saying that the father has
always been the father then that means
that he's always had a son no that
doesn't that's why when I said the
mother and father I was trying to help
you understand the metaphor of How It's
not literal that Christ is the literal
son like no I I get that right but then
you just brought that up so I don't
think you got it and then I tried to
give you another example when I said
Abraham is the father of faith faith is
not a child either it's a metaphor so
he's always the father because it's talk
about him being the foundation he's
always been the foundation all right so
but the I'll give another one more
example when Christ says um when it says
he shall declare our sin in Isaiah the
53rd chapter he shall declare his seed
yeah Christ didn't literally have us
even though we know that's talking about
Christ it's a metaphor of a relationship
yeah you sure you got it now no so you I
don't think that you was understand the
point I was attacking you brought up an
example saying that if he's the father
then that must mean that he came before
the son because fathers come before
their son correct right okay so when you
said that's what I was attacking if
you're saying that fathers always come
before their sons and you say at the
same time God has always been the father
that means that he's always been the son
you're not a father until you have a son
right and what I had to clarify for you
is that in that context Christ didn't
exist but the most high was always the
father because he's the father of
everything there was nothing for him to
be a father of of course but how does
everything start from the Father the
father is the found before Christ died
EXC me did did does Christ declare our
seed say that again does Christ declare
our seed in according to Isaiah 53 is he
Our Father yes so how is that a metaphor
yeah that that's a metaphor right so the
father and Christ the father and son
is the metaphor of a subordinate
relationship I got so in colians 1:5
when it says he is the beginning of the
firstborn of all creation is the father
created no the father is not created and
neither is the son because the next
verse tells you why he's called
firstborn like for example can we read
it well sure we can pull it up but but
let me let me ask you this is is is
David was David the first king of Israel
no was David the oldest of his family no
but David is called the firstborn the
highest of the kings of the Earth right
so was he the firstborn King Israel the
verse excuse me the verse I quoted was
Israel is my son even my first born he's
not the first nation born either exactly
so you're proving my point no no what
you're saying is look you're saying
you're you you're taking firstborn
literally in in Colossians 1 but
recognizing that it can be used
figuratively elsewhere no I'm not taking
firstborn literally okay I'm taking
beginning Christ is the beginning of the
things that the Most High created that's
the only thing okay so my position is
that the Most High created Christ and
then charged Christ with doing
everything else that's what verse 9 19
tells you it says it pleased the father
that in him should all fullness dwell so
that means the father chose Christ and
said I'mma put everything in your power
yes so the father gave it to him Christ
didn't take it Christ couldn't demand it
Christ couldn't even do it himself the
father gave it to him well okay so this
is where the the the the substance of
this is though cuz you're saying when
he's the beginning of the creation of
God the word is Arc which means Source
he's the source of the beginning he's
the source of all creation because
everything was created by Him and
through him if under whose authority
though we can say the fathers no problem
okay so once you say there's a father
there he can't be the god of that that's
not true that is true somebody's given
him power no he didn't it doesn't say he
gave him power it said it please the
father that him should all said he wait
wait in Matthews 28:8 Christ says all
power is given to me but you just said
no no no that's not what I'm saying so
what you're talking about is the context
of him when he came in the flesh and he
humbled himself set aside his authority
to handle his work on Earth that's not
what that's not what Matthew 28 that's
exactly what it's talking about no when
it says all authority is given to him
it's talk about every bit of power that
he gained for being obedient author so
now he had to ask for the glory to be
given back that means he's subordinate
what Glory though the glory that he had
in the beginning so he had this Glory
before I never said he didn't have the
glory no I know so he had this Glory
before he had this Authority this this
status before and then we see he's in a
state where he's made a little lower
than put him in that state he he he was
sent by the father willfully came who
put in that state he and the Father the
don't say that John 3:16 Says for God so
loved the world he sent his only
begotten son and in John said and 10:1
17 why does the father love the son
because he's obedient because he says I
lay down my life for the Sheep so it's
his choice he's coming and he says no
one takes it from me he's doing this no
no no when you say he's doing it what
he's doing this of his valtion and of
the father's Val no he's doing it
because the father said so when when
Christ was when Christ knew he was about
to die yeah what did he ask the father
he said he said if it's possible take
this cup from me but will be what was
his will well if you're talking about
what was his will I'm about to answer
you B dog get
in about you B
dog so so water so so what you have here
is you have Jesus right um um with
within his human nature he's having his
human will submit to the Divine will
obviously here he's a man full of
Sorrows so what was his will though so
so right there you see the human will is
to have the cup passed from him but you
also see his will saying
not my will let your will be done so UL
him yielding to Authority so his will
Ying to God so his will is ultimately is
for the father's will to be done but you
said he wanted to if it was up to him he
wouldn't have done it no not not true at
all he did it because he was given an
order right yeah but but he wanted this
no no no he said he wanted the cup to
pass you can't want the cup to pass and
then say not my will if it's his will
that's what does the my will represent
at the same time just dealing with
exactly what you just said at the same
time ultimately he says let your will be
done I don't want to get to the ultimate
because you made it seem like they was
on the same Accord which they are on the
same Accord but they on the same Accord
because of what the father wanted but
it's also if it was up to Christ it is
what he wanted he wanted what the father
wanted okay his will was what to let the
cup pass and so if okay if he's going to
I'm going to get to the second part cuz
I brought this up so if will is to let
the cup pass you can't say that they was
on the same page as far as what they
both wanted one obeyed the other wanted
God wanted Christ to die Christ wanted
something else but Christ obeyed what
the father wanted not what he wanted
fact that's facts that's what the
scriptures say the scriptures say not my
will but your will that's what make
Christ the man Christ is the man because
he never did his own will he did the
will of the father right so let let me
respond to this so the reason why I'm
saying that there is a discrepancy with
how you're breaking this down is because
you're saying that Jesus in the first
place didn't want this when all the
scriptures power he's saying I came for
this reason I lay down my life for the
Sheep no one takes it from me I do this
of my own accord I have the authority to
take lay it down and authority to pick
it back up again this charge I've
received from my father he's in perfect
alignment with the father I never said
he wasn't in alignment okay good but
like real but like real life I'm sorry
so when he gets to the point of the
Garden of Gethsemane we see the struggle
we see the grievance and the sorrow that
he's well the scripture tells us he says
that he's acquainted with grief a man
because what he's facing he's taking on
the because now it's about to be real so
like what you thank you so now what what
him saying I'm going to be sacrificed
raised up three days all these things
he's saying all that and he's in
agreement with it and I'm in agreement
with it but then it get real life and
when real life hits now that's when he
got the grief like man I'm about to go
through it and then he goes to the
father and prays if it be possible my
will is to let this cup pass because now
it's going to be real life it's like if
you got anything anything you preparing
to do you could be preparing for
anything and then when it's go time you
might be a little nervous you might be a
little jittery and so Christ was the
same way so my point is he was
subordinate to something else so he
can't be God God don't report but see
okay so this is where we're getting it
you're you're you're conflating uh a
role and status with nature so just
because Jesus humbles himself before the
father doesn't take away his divine
nature this is why I'm saying when he
said when the scripture says that for by
him all things were created I don't
argue that though but you do though cuz
you're saying he didn't create the
father well well the father is not a
thing is he thank you so then there's
something that existed before Christ was
told to do what he did the father
created Christ told Christ go do all of
this and he do it so that beginning and
everything after that has nothing to do
with the father what does all things
mean all things means everything except
the father okay so he's not he's
excluded cuz he's not a thing created
right right okay so but I mean don't
don't don't make things so cynical cuz
you got Angels you got people you got
animals and Christ is responsible for it
all Christ Christ is responsible under
the authority of the father even what
you just quoted Christ said I do nothing
of my own but of him that sent me so
even out of his own words he sub
to God well all right so but this is the
problem though okay like I said again
You're conflating subordination role or
humility with nature like if I'm
subordinate to like you you're a captain
you got people under you just because
they're subordinate to you don't make
them any less human than you it don't
change their nature you're both human
even though you are captain and they may
you know I don't know what the you told
me the ranks early about you want a
water uh yeah please thank you you got
another one told you y'all see this
y'all see how
man appreciate it man no sweat no sweat
but but it do so subordination and
humility or status a rank has nothing to
do with one's nature so that's what
we're discussing but you you are you're
saying because he's subordinate to the
father that means he's not God by no
that's not what I'm saying I'm
explaining subordination just to break
down the order like for example does
Jesus have a God yes or no he yeah he
submits to the father as his God he just
said he wait do you want you want me to
break that down am I being punked he
said I'm making you just said I'm making
this submissive argument and then you
just said excuse me subordinate argument
and then you just said he's submissive
to the father yeah do you so so again
did I say that he's submissive to the
father that what argument was you make
it with me you so you made this whole
subordinate argument only to agree that
he submits to God he's submissive to God
so so for examp but the debate title is
Jesus God yeah that's the debate title
not is he humble to God not is he
submissive see you're conflating I ask
you if Jesus has a God anduh and what
what was my answer you said yes he
submissive to would you like me to
explain that okay before you do that the
scripture just just a scripture
reference in 1 Corinthians 11:3 that's
the scripture I'm references it says the
head of every man is Jesus and the head
of Christ is God the father so I need
you to explain how that doesn't mean
that Jesus have a God cuz I'm assuming
you about to wiggle out of it well no
what I'm what I'm showing you is that
just because the head of Christ is God
the father doesn't take away from Jesus
having the same divine nature as the
father just like if your captain tesar
is the head of Trooper uh you know
Israel you know what I'm saying that
don't mean that Trooper Israel is not
human like Captain Tarak so what I'm
saying or like for example if the head
of every woman is man are they not both
human so notice how this is talking
about rank not not nature so what I'm
saying is is that yes Christ humbles
himself to the father he's subordinate
to the father willfully but that doesn't
take away that he himself shares the
same Divine Eternal nature as the father
as we see what the scripture says for by
him all things were created was he
created if you say yes then you have to
say that the father created Jesus
through Jesus that makes no sense
there's no scripture that say that the
father created Jesus through Jesus but
when people want to make Jesus God you
just said that the head of Jesus Is God
correct yes the father so if the you you
said God the Father yes he's the of
Christ why do you say God the Father
before I continue because I want to make
sure I'm very clear with our language
here I got to make sure that we're
talking about the person of the father
where you're talking about God being the
head of Jesus since we talk of
scriptures 1 Corinthians 8:5 says though
there be many that are called Gods
whether in heaven or Earth but to us
there is one God the father so if you
bring in another God besides Christ then
you don't understand the scripture and
then the very next verse says and one
Lord Christ and any man can be called
lord David is called lord Abraham is
called lord a lot of men are called lord
so now we have two scripture references
where the scripture Paul says to us
there is one God the father he didn't
say two he didn't say three so now what
we have read what we have read
Colossians you have the father giv power
to his son Matthews 28 you have the
father excuse me Christ asking the
father or saying that the father gave
him power John 17 Christ saying give me
the glory that I once had he's asking
somebody for Glory and in 1 Corinthians
11:3 it says the head of Christ is God
okay so did you land okay all right got
you so this is my problem with this cap
this is my problem man so cuz you keep
going back to you keep going back to
subordination no this ain't sub wait
wait I'm wait before you go just just 10
seconds stop flipping what I'm saying to
subordination I'm not what saying
because what I'm showing is that Jesus
has a
God the head of Christ is God got Jesus
has a God that he talks to that he gets
power from that he gets Authority from
so there is somebody over him that's my
position it's not subordination that's
what you're talking about okay all right
that God exists outside of Christ okay
so let's talk about this cuz you brought
up 1 Corinthians 8 you said for us
there's one God he said the next part
where it says there's one only one Lord
is the father Lord yes the father is
Lord but it says there's only one Lord
right so so just because it says there's
only one God the Father you're saying
that excludes Christ from being God but
when it says there's only one Lord Jesus
Christ that doesn't exclude the father's
being Lord that's that's your argument
he give him around give y y ain't going
to clap for him clap for him that's it
was it was ass but you like that no no I
didn't but I your word salad is good
thank you because cook he trying to jump
out the pot man no so cuz you just said
because to us there is one God and then
you said one Lord and you made it seem
like that word Lord in that context is
talk about like Lord if we said yahwah
or y'all may say Jehovah y' may say
Yahweh that's not the Lord that it's
talking about it's talking about a lord
like if you said a ruler right exactly
so it's not talking about the most
High's name like Psalms 8 that's not my
argument what is the point of bringing
up the one Lord the one yeah so my
argument is clean up I'm going help you
out so you can catch up to no I'm I'm
caught I'm caught
little behind cuz you made that one Lord
seem like that one Lord is talk now
that's this how I know that you don't
even understand what I said look I do
cuz you're talking subordination no this
is what you did okay this is what you
did everybody saw it everybody pay
attention you said according to the
scripture there's only it says there's
only one God the father so to say
there's any God outside the father man
you going against the scripture right
right so that so I I said okay let's see
if you're going to be consistent in the
next verse it says it says right same
same sentence right same sentence it
says and to us there's only one Lord
Jesus Christ now I asked you is I asked
you is the father Lord you said
yes I'm not laughing at I know I know I
know I know Hallelujah man that's right
that's right but that but that one I'm
sorry so so to be I'm just holding you
to be consistent with your argument and
how you're understanding the verse
you're saying there's one God the Father
according to the verse so you can't
identify anybody else as God okay so I'm
like okay let's see if you're consistent
it says there's one Lord Jesus Christ do
you identify anybody else as Lord you
said yes the father so you're being
inconsistent you ask me as the Lord the
father in the context that that's
talking about that
subordination you have God the Father
it's only one we agree right yes only
one yes the Lord is like we don't have
another Lord or Master there ain't
nobody else like you know you might have
a God but all cuz that subject of 1
Corinthians the 8th chapter is about
different God
so you can have a all that you might
call Lord you can have any of other
Greek gods that you might call Lord we
don't have that just like false right
right just like we don't have no other
gods the whole subject is to say though
and that verse five says though there be
many gods whether in Earth or in heaven
so there's a lot of things called Gods
but to us when we say God we say the
father now some instances we're going to
call him the Lord or yahawah and then we
have one Lord or Master because that
that represents who the father sent yeah
so this right here in this verse it's
not talking about yahawah that the name
it's not talking about the T no not the
L part right but the god part the father
is signifying there's only one God yeah
but there's It also says that there's
only one Lord Kos that's right so but
you also said that the father is Lord
Kos right not in that context the
subject this the word if you're going to
use the Greek word that's crazy because
there's a Hebrew people that are talking
so that word Lord is going to be but
it's still people talking Paul was a
Hebrew was he not using the Greek was
Paul a Israelite yes using the Greek we
can use any language okay if you go if
you go into if you go well let's get
consistent second magabe 6:6 they made
it illegal to be a Jew and then we
became hellenized so we start speaking
different languages just like in America
we speaking English this ain't our
native language so we speaking in the
land of our captivity Paul was an
Israelite from The Tribe of Benjamin but
he was a Roman citizen so he's talking
to Greek speaking Jews let not be
cynical so now I'm saying that because
that word Lord is going to be the same
everywhere in the Greek just like the
word world is going to be the same
everywhere in the Greek even though
we're going to know that there's a
different context when we see the word
world just like it's a different context
when we see the word Lord so the word
Lord in that context is not getting rid
of the most high being called lord it's
letting us know we have one boss so we
have one king or we have one ruler and
that's who the father set up so again
that verse says to us there is one God
you're giving us two Gods you're giving
us father God and you're giving us
excuse me God the father and you're
giving us God the son okay that's what
you're giving us I'm not so what I'm and
who's the other what is Jesus to you the
reason why I'm saying he's the second
person of of the Trinity of the divine
nature not he's not a God okay so just
for clarity you're saying God the Father
God the son and God the Holy Spirit yes
that's not in the Bible either well well
it actually is though if well that's
what I'm showing you I can show you the
scripture where well you you you don't
argue that the father's God but the the
scripture calls the son God as well
Isaiah 9:6 as you know um it calls mes
God Romans 51 it's Moses no he no but it
said that he will be as God to will be
his Prophet who who said who made him
God I wanted to address your verse we
going to come back to that problem come
back to it so what I'm saying is look
when it says there's one God from whom
are all things right and then one Lord
Jesus Christ by through whom right says
by whom by whom are and then Jesus
Christ through whom are all things no no
no when the beginning says there's one
God the father of whom are all things
and then one Lord Jesus Christ by whom
okay so it's like the father is how
everything is done and it's through
Christ yeah he carries it out even
that's subordination even that's you see
how he said it again is that word right
that's subordination because that I told
you that verse is subordination and
we're not arguing subordination you're
right we are arguing that
we are arguing that Christ submits to
something over him yes in author what is
that no no no no that entity or that
power is called God he's called so is
the son called he's called the most high
God why is he even called the most high
God wait so are you are you're trying to
argue that Jesus is not the most high
God yeah he's not right why is he called
why is he called the most high God
because he's higher than all he's he's
he's he's God is it not because anybody
else can be called a god 82 and6 says ye
are Gods no but it no so but they're not
they're not true they're not the true
God I didn't say nothing about true God
I'm talking about the word God that's
what confuses Christians what confuses
Christians is that Christians believe
that like when I immediately said Psalms
82 and6 year are God you said not the
true God y the reason why the most high
is called the most high God because
other entities can be called Gods
Pharaoh's called a god Moses was made a
God by excuse me by the most high
was he not yeah he made
him andet God said not behold I have
made thee a God to Pharaoh so now Moses
is a God now okay but but my point is
he's not Divine though right you're
saying that he's a Jud we not talking
about as God to and that's the same
thing as Christ Christ being called a
God is not making him the most high
that's why he never took a most high
position never call himself good and
when they try to tell him in John the
10th chapter when he said I am my father
or one right what did they try to do
they tried to Stone him right Y and they
said of a good works we Stone thee not
but thou makest thyself a god did he
agree or disagree with that no he didn't
disagree with what they were saying he
you said he didn't disagree he didn't
disagree with them so he agreed that he
was making himself God yes wa cuz I
could have swore in that verse he said
thou if does it not say in your law ye
are
and if this is the word of God which
can't be broken say thou of him that
says I am the Son of God that's what he
said so where did he say he was God well
he said so this this is where we're at
he didn't disagree or rebuke what they
said c come come on back come come back
come
back listen listen he didn't refute what
they said so calling he did refute what
they said let me respond to you a better
word he cut them on what they said I I
got you so let me respond to this cuz
you you went on a long time so when
you're talking
about when you're talking about how
Jesus responded he didn't say no I'm not
making myself out to be God but he
accused them of being these false judges
who's accusing them of blasphemy for
claiming to be God when he says he is
the Son of God he's claiming it in that
he's equal with the father and shares
the same nature as the father this is
why I'm saying when he says when he says
isn't it in your law that that it says
that I said you are Gods now in this
context these are these Gods who are
supposed to be righteous judges right
and not showing partiality they're
supposed to judge righteously but
they're Jud isites right right yeah they
Israelites but they're judging Christ
falsely for blasphemy so he applies this
scripture he applies this scripture to
them because they're falsely accusing
him of blasphemy when he's claiming to
be God by saying I am the Son of God
he's not claim if he wanted to 30 more
minutes okay if he was claiming to be
the Son of God he would excuse me to be
God one thing about Christ he didn't lie
that's right and if he was claiming to
be God he would have just said so not
true that doesn't I give another Cesar
said it Caesar said it the uh I we
didn't talk about what Caesar said we
didn't even talk about what the Jews
said we talk about what Christ said
Christ said I am there's so many
scripture Matthew 19 and 17 he said why
callest thou me good there's none good
but one that is God he never said two is
Jesus good I can call him good what did
he say what did he say about himself
look look look I'm I'm glad listen give
him a hand give him a hand I'm glad I
could teach I'm glad I could teach
listen I teach a lot of my I teach a lot
of my combatants how to have a good
skill set so now when you say there's
none good but one that is God and if
thou will enter into life keep the
Commandments if you'll let me finish
it's going to go bad for you in John 20
and 17 did he not say I go to my father
and your father I go to my God and your
God yeah why though
see you got to let let me break that
down cuz this is what you was bringing
up earlier and I wanted to break this
down to you the Bible says in Jeremiah
32:27 he says that God is the God of All
Flesh right in the beginning was the
word the word was with God and the Word
was so the word is God and what happened
to the word he became flesh so that
means that the father is the god of his
flesh all right so that's why Jesus can
say in his flesh that I have a God over
me not that he himself is a separate God
or that he's not God in the same sense
the father is so he submits to the
father and by his Human by his Humanity
the father is his God that's the context
of that you got to take it all in
scripture man all it C so before before
I fully respond I just want a yes or no
question so you saying there's more than
one God no thank you for saying that
okay relax everybody thank thank you for
saying that because you really do y'all
Christians really say that there is more
than one God that verse just said that
that verse just said in John 20 and 17
go to my father and your father I go to
my God and your God and then his
argument is to bring up John 1:1 when it
says the word is God I told yall earlier
these are Hebrew people the word God in
Hebrew is Elohim some may say alah and
those are Israelites like myself that
word means power Angel messenger
Authority ruler Etc so when it says in
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the Word was God that's
the word there for God is power it's not
make making him God it's not it's just
that simple otherwise when it talks
about the angels and you see that word
Elohim I guess they're Gods too but when
I bought out Psalms 82 and6 which used
the same word Elohim he said no that's
not God because that word is used to
describe Prince Angel messenger ruler
Authority judges all of that so again
Christ clearly said in John 20 and 17 I
go to my God
and your God so if he's reporting to
something if he's report IM go even
further when he when the Holy Spirit um
when he got baptized what was the voice
that spoke to him was that the father
and what's the father God based on First
Corinthians right that's right so Christ
wasn't talking to himself right he
talking to the father another God God
yeah so show me where Christ called
himself God oh so before I I'll get you
that just just one second cuz you
brought up John 1:1 like he was
responding to it for the record when I
say God I mean the most high God
absolutely we we'll show that in a
second but when you're talking about the
most high God who's creator of all
things and all these things right he
himself is UNC is uncreated he doesn't
have beginning or an end but when it
comes to the word it says not only that
he's God so he's not just God in the
sense that he's like an angel a prince a
ruler that type of thing but he's God
the creator of all things of Heaven and
Earth how do we know this because in
verse three it says about the word who
is God it says um that through him all
things were made and without him
anything that was made was made through
him without him there was not anything
made that was made you believe you you
agree that Jesus is the word right he's
the word of God definitely the word so
Jesus he's a word of what the word the
word of God right so there's a God and
then there's a word he just cut I guess
I guess but but when it says the word is
God we cut ourselves huh he he admitted
that Jesus is the word and says the word
that word God is power though that word
is not okay so so let's talk about this
then if he if the word is God right was
the word made yes okay so it literally
says that apart from him without him
nothing made was made without him so
everything that was made everything that
came into existence came into existence
through the word so did the word come
into existence through the word no the
word had to be created oh give him a
hand the word had to be
created we're going right back to
Colossians who is the first born who is
the image of the invisible God the first
born of all creation that's preeminence
that's once again so in John 1 when you
says the word and you said did the word
exist uh uh before no it didn't it had
to be created it says that he's in the
beginning with God was there in the
beginning God of course he was in the
beginning because he's the first thing
created in the beginning it says nothing
that it says nothing that was made you
can't have a father that gives somebody
power that 1 Corinthians 8:6 it says to
us there is one God the Father by whom
excuse me who made all things I'm
paraphrasing the scripture and then one
Lord Jesus Christ by whom so the pecking
order is the father has the power to
give it to who he wants and he gave that
power to Christ to do what he wants just
like he made Moses a God to do what he
wants just like he made Elijah call fire
out of Heaven to do what he wants just
like he made Elijah raise somebody from
the dead to do what he wants the most
high can do whatever it is he wants to
do Christ can't do what he want to do I
got you can question can Christ do what
he want to do he can and it's always
show me where Christ can do what hold on
because we're not getting away from this
you're trying to get away from this no
I'm not it says look it says about the
word all things that means all right all
things except the father right he's not
a thing he's not a thing so he's but we
are not things either we are yes we are
we're creation we are we are we are
Creations we could be beasts but we're
not things yes we are bro I mean that's
simple English like noun so it says all
things were created through him and
nothing without him nothing that has
been made is it been made was made you
believe the word was made yes so that
would is the word Christ so yes so the
word is Christ and the word is made no
okay so if you're saying that what does
it mean to be the word let me L this
okay if you're saying that that that the
word is made then you have to say cap
you have to say if you're going to be
consistent that the word created himself
that the father created the word through
the word cuz nothing word came into
being without word what does the word
mean the Loos no what is the no no no I
ain't talking about the the meaning of
the word but when you see the word what
does that mean the the one who explains
God the wi explains who explains the
father explains God the
Father okay
he that mean says he's the word of God
he receives the instructions from the
father and then gives us the word of God
that's why he's the word that's not my
question my question no I didn't say
that was your question I'm saying that's
what the when when it's calling him the
word he's receiving something we're
receiving when Christ spoke he said the
words that I speak are not mine who are
the words that so so you're you're
conflating the father's words speaking
audibly with the word of God who
explains the
father when he said he spoke the words
what words he spoke
are you saying that the father's words
that he spoke is the same thing as Jesus
being the word what words did he speak
when he spoke his words he said the
words are not mine who whose words did
he speak he's speaking the gospel he's
speaking of the father's words of the
father's right so the father gave him
what to say right so so no no worries is
Jesus that's why he's the word but no
that's not what it says though see cap
you're not even explaining it right when
you're talking about the father's words
you said Jesus is the word be super good
by the time I think I'm pretty good now
you believe that Jesus is the word right
I believe that and you believe that the
father also spoke words to him right yes
so the father is speaking words to the
word yes okay so do you see the
distinction there so you over like doing
your back when you say see the
distinction give me what you mean when
you so there's a distinction between the
the spoken words of the father and the
person who's the identified as the's
only called the word because he's the
one getting the word directly from the
father like when St looked up like when
Steven looked up to the to the sky and
saw God and saw Christ standing on the
right hand he didn't see Jesus and God
as one he saw them separate he saw them
he saw the distinction not a separation
was Jesus from the tribe of Judah in
heaven yes shom I almost walked away
from you almost walked away from you so
Jesus still an Israelite in heaven in
heaven cuz he has flesh so is God an
Israelite the son God the son is
Israelite yes no no no no I didn't ask
you I didn't ask you about God the son
that's what Romans God and Israelite yes
the God yeah God the son because because
he took on flesh is an Israelite
according to his clip this right here he
said God what tribe from the word what
Tri God from the word who is God you can
do that all you want that don't do
nothing the word who is God you got to
deal with the argument the word who is
God became
flesh let me answer you man the word who
is God is crazy the word who is God
became flesh and the scripture says I'm
literally answering you cap come on man
but you're not answering what I'm asking
I'm literally ask you're asking what
what tribe is is God from that's what
you ask I'm giving you the answer the
first thing said was was is Christ a
Israelite in heaven and did I and what
was my answer your answer was yes thank
you that's Revelation the fth chapter
can I elaborate but Christ is Before the
Throne you're not letting meor okay go
ahead all right thank you go ahead so I
said the word you might your audience
word the word is God uhhuh God because
he's the word became flesh according to
the scripture and according to his flesh
he's born of the tribe of Judah a
descendant of David so that's how I can
say God is of the tribe of Israel
according to what his flesh so you need
to deal with this argument instead of
turning to the crowd and saying man look
at this right here that's not an
argument you got to deal with the
argument and now and you try to run away
from this it says that all things were
made through him and nothing that was
made was made without him so if he
himself is made you have to say that
Jesus Christ was made through Jesus
Christ I want to hear you say it
say it you done yeah I want to hear you
say it say Jesus Christ was made through
Jesus
Christ that's probably like the first
genuine laugh you got up out of me so
now here's here's the windmill you just
did the windmill you just did what I
just asked you was is Christ from the
tribe of Judah in heaven because now
what that does is that eliminates this
his human nature versus spiritual nature
in heaven no one can open that scroll
the 24 Elders is like nobody can open
the scroll and then we have him the lion
of David from the tribe of Judah being
presented before the father who we
already established he's called God and
so that's the God so now once I asked
you is God from a tribe you said yeah
it's not in context to John 1:1 which
already broke down that the word God in
that context is Elohim and Elohim means
power messenger Angel Authority it's not
calling him the most high or yahawah
it's not calling him that so you can't
combine and cherry pick or run or what
yall is G you can't isog that context
and then make it that when Revelations 5
Christ is Before the Throne from the
tribe of Judah and on the throne is the
father and that's God so you can't now
say that God is from a tribe I ain't
never heard listen as many arguments and
battles I had about Jesus's God you the
first cat that ever told me that Jesus
excuse me that God is from a tri Christ
and so to get back to your question when
you say that if Christ created all
things then you're saying Jesus created
Jesus specifically it says that nothing
that has been made right but John 1 and3
right John 1 and3 is the same thing as
colians that we was just talking about
the father no because the father gave
Christ the power to do that to do what
to create all things did he give him the
power to create himself he didn't have
to create himself because the father
this is this is so idiotic the father he
didn't have to when I'm saying didn't
have to create himself I'm talking about
the most high no no you said Jesus
didn't have to create himself no because
the father created him but he wait hold
on it says that all things that were
made were made through except him where
does it say that it doesn't say he
created himself where does it say he
created himself that's that's a that
must be swine man that got to be pork
cooking that got to be pork precept give
a precept man give it a precept that got
to be Park you cooking no because
there's no scripture that he created
himself he did not create himself so
what look so look stop if if there's no
scripture that says that he so that
means always
existed then what we then what we have
to do is go by the scriptures that we
have and if the scriptures say who is
the the image of the invisible God the
firstborn of all creation and then it
talks about all the things which is just
like John 1:3 it breaks down everything
that he created and then it says for it
pleased the father that in him should
all fullness dwell common sense not
Christianity tells me the father gave
him that power and then you have to now
translate that with other scriptures so
the other scriptures of his glory when
he asked for his glory he didn't take it
back he asked for it back you say I a
run away you are how did I I've clearly
just told you Colossians 1 and9 once it
says it please the father that in him
should all fullness dwell that mean
there's a father looking at his son
saying I'mma give you this Authority cap
that's not that's facts that's two
different entities all right one more
time cap and then and I'll ask you just
one more time me was all things made
through
Jesus by by the most high okay so all
things like First Corinthians 8 say it
say it so all things by the most high
was created through Jesus was Jesus
created by the most high so then that
would mean that Jesus by the most high
was created through Jesus by the most
high I feel sorry for you Christians man
sorry for
you man you can't keep talking about
style you got to come up with something
on your own I'm also a showman too you
know this the chef hey when he go back
at debate I'm going to see him copying
everything anyway but the Father the
father got to pull from all the gra the
father gave something to the son what he
give him the power where does it say
that and it pleased the father that in
him should all fullness dwell if it
disle could he take it from him huh if
it displeased him could he take it from
him if it if so number one there's never
going to be any displeasing or any that
doesn't help you there can never be any
displeasing in the father and the son
they're always in perfect un that's
impossible I'm answering you look this
is your question so if it say it pleased
the father that mean he was pleased at
creating Christ and then telling Christ
to go do these things yes but this is
what this yes I said yes that but but
you ask me can there ever be any
displeasure in the from the father and
the son to where he takes something away
from the son that there's never any I
don't mean that in a literal sense cuz
you don't read that cuz he was obedient
what I'm saying is the fact that it says
it pleased him okay that mean that
that's something that the father was
pleased in his creation pleased in what
he saw in his son and then gave his son
the power to do those things that
doesn't answer my question through who
was Jesus created Christ I'm Excuse me
the most high where does it say that
give me the verse where it says that
through the most high Jesus was created
Colossians 1 and 19 Colossians 1:9 just
says that in him he saw he was pleased
that all fact have don't answer that and
if you go to Daniel I think it's Daniel
7 when it talked about the Ancient of
Days did sit and then the son of man is
coming before him the son the most high
has always been on his throne wait hold
on the most high there the word is
plural when when you talk about the
Ancient of Days on the throne well in
Daniel 7 when it mentions the most high
is in verse 18 22 well every time you
see the word God is is plural you got to
look at the context yeah but who who the
most highs in Daniel 7 you have to tell
me what verse you're talking about so
I'm talking about so you got Daniel 7
like when we when the Ancient of Days
first appears you see in verse 9 right
I'm talking specifically like when he's
um sitting on the throne and then the
son of man is being brought before him
but how many Thrones are mentioned well
there's two Thrones if you go to
Revelations 3 and 21 when Christ says
them that um I'm paraphrasing them that
uh endure uh will sit with me on my
Throne as I sit with my father in his
throne even in the heavens there's two
Thrones so if there's two Thrones you
got God on one throne and you got Christ
on another Throne right absolutely now
now with this when it continues to go it
talks about how the Saints of the most
high right it says the Saints of the
most high I think that's later down in
the chapter yeah later down what I'm
talking about yeah what I'm talking
about is the Ancient of Days is sitting
on his throne and then the son of man is
coming to him yeah but my question is
this who's that son of man well that's
Jesus my point my point is this though
who are the most highs that is talking
about mostos High show me no you got to
show me I don't you got to show me what
you talking about I'm not aare um is it
it's in Daniel 7 I could probably find
it quicker yeah it's in Daniel you got
bab give me that's Baba right here give
me bab so we go to Daniel 7 and we go to
I before if you just pause I think we
should be both applauded for being able
to go with 20 40 minutes without pulling
out one actual Bible verse and everybody
understanding and following I think
that's amazing in itself 10 more minutes
10 more minutes until this debate is
done all right so we go to you say Dan s
yes Sir Daniel 7 so the one I was
talking about um is verse 9 when it says
and beheld to the Thrones were cast down
in the Ancient of Days did sit whose
garment was white as snow that's the
verse I was talking about but you said
there was another one yeah so when you
continue to read down as like as as you
said the yes Thrones and Y uh maybe 22
until the Ancient of Days came and
judgment was given to the Saints of the
most high is that what you're talking
about yeah that's that's one 18 is one
too verse 18 verse 18 it says but the
Saints of the most high shall take the
kingdom and possess the kingdom forever
and ever you saying that word most high
is plural I'm assuming in
Hebrew let me pull my don't callot me
ELO Elohim or something like that eloh
but Elohim is no not Elohim it's like um
not he it's a a different different type
cuz Elohim is plal in itself for me go
to Bible Hub I have a uh a blue letter
app on my phone so I'm going to grab it
cuz Elohim is plural always that's why
important this context so you said
Daniel 7 and8 so I'm going to go to the
Interline Interlinear and he talk about
El Yan yeah you talk about the most high
you talk about
that that's what the most that's that's
the word and then and that word is in in
the plural in uh but it says um 22 but
it's in 22 you says yeah in 18 it's
plural but it's 18 it's not plural in 18
it is well let me back up one I'm going
show you I ain't going to beat him up
y'all he say let me show you so this is
Daniel 7 and 18 right yeah so that's
the it says L there so when I click it
it goes that and it goes to most high
then um those are the different
definitions right there yeah yeah it
gives it gives it the definition doesn't
give part of
speech sayal Hebrew of God and then now
if I do the 22 if I go back one more you
said 22 as well so if I go 22 that's 22
right
there my back appreciate so if I go to
22 right there and I do the Interlinear
so you see right there Ancient of Days
judgment and the Saints of the most high
right there yeah see most high so I'm
going click that and then you see it's
the same word yeah yeah that's the def
that's the that's the root word there
right right yeah so what I'm saying word
let me see let me see if I I got oh you
got like
me right and say it's the masculine
plural right that that's what I showed
you in here look when I showed you down
here when I said um Biblical Hebrew
plural of God yeah but Elohim and those
I'm going switch back but this is the
word for the most high but all those
words is all those words are plural in
Hebrew no it's not because there's this
what I'm saying if you go to verse 27 it
has most high in the singular and it
also has most high you said in Daniel 7
and 27 yes
sir and what when what I looked up it
was always singular which you're looking
down at in the definitions that it can
be plural but you said Daniel 7 and 27
yeah Daniel 727 uhhuh um
so I'm going go to the most high there
that's also the same L Lon now when you
look up the Strong's definition or when
you go down biblical Aramaic it'll tell
you that the word is Biblical Hebrew
plural of God but when you look up any
of the words Elohim or Lon is 25 Daniel
7 and 25 yeah Daniel 7:25 it uses most
high in a singular uhhuh and then uh
uses um I'm assuming that's somebody
telling you that you talk about how it's
written in Hebrew yes it's which one is
it in plural again give me that one all
right so in the plural it's the Elohim
no which no no which verse yeah yeah um
that's verse that's verse 22 and verse
27 okay so when I I had went to 22
earlier it says until the Ancient of
Days came and judgment was given to the
Saints of the most high and the time
came that he that the Saints possessed
him there's nothing in this verse that
will pluralize that concept no the word
the word most high in the Hebrew is
plural it's it's Elohim when no no no
I get what you're saying I don't have a
problem with that because as you can see
right there it's the same way but when I
when I'm I'm sorry I didn't mean to do
that but what I'm saying is Elan if I go
to Psalms 83 for example when it says
Thou whose name alone art the most high
over all the Earth it's that same
pluralized version that you say that's
Psalms 83 yeah Psalms 83 and the last
verse when it says that men may know
that thou whose name is yahawah Art the
most high over all the Earth you'll see
the same thing let see so Psalm at the
to said 83 yeah see where it says see it
right here I'm sorry it's this one I mic
again my bad turn it on so it's this one
see how we got the plural right there
see how it's
plural where do you see the I'm I'm
sorry I'm sorry see and see the Hebrew
is written in plural that's how it has
the on there yeah that's the on there so
that verse is saying yeah so that that
verse is saying that thou whose name
alone art the the most high over all the
Earth so even that just because you see
the E on the end of it just like the
Elohim you see the E on the end of it
you have to look at the context so it's
not right no problem so in the Ancient
of Days you got the Ancient of Days and
the son of man who are ruling in heaven
and who all serve and worship nobody say
that they don't rule together nobody I
never said that the father don't rule
with the son this kind this subject is
is Jesus God and he's not you have the
throne that the father sits on and you
have a Throne that Christ has yeah so
who who's the Lord of lords in
heaven yeah who's the Lord of lords in
heaven yeah they both sit on the throne
who's the Lord of lords in heaven well
the most high is the Lord period Christ
can have the but there's one Lord Jesus
Christ
Christ there's only one Lord remember if
if I could tell why y'all slow because
when we read all throughout the the Old
Testament and New Testament you can see
God or Lord used for the most high once
again in First Corinthians the 8th
chapter as I explained listening is an
art you can see that when it says to us
there is one God the father that doesn't
take away that you can't call him Lord
that doesn't take away and the same
thing for the for the son just because
it says there's one God the Father it
doesn't take away that the son is also
God thank you very much it takes
everything away the whole point of that
verse if there was more than one God it
would say to us there is Gods the father
and the son and it wouldn't wrong listen
I wouldn't even fight it if that's what
the scriptures say but the script the
scripture don't say that the scripture
say there's one God well we have had
throughout this whole demonstration
Christ has only called himself the Son
of God in the Bible that's not it that's
not the only thing he calls himself like
here it is again he called himself son
of man well who's the Lord of lords in
heaven who's the Lord of lords well why
don't you read to me what you're talking
about I'm asking the question I'm asking
you to read what you're talking about
think you're I'm just asking you you're
talking about I'm just asking a question
and and here's why I'm asking the
question you just tried to pluralize
Elon which is not I'm not finished don't
get don't get too touchy you just tried
to pluralize Elon to make a false point
when Elon is plural just like Elohim is
plural okay so before I go down your
rabbit hole I just want the verse that
you talk like paraphrase it so no so I
didn't make the false point I was using
it no no I'm talking about now this this
whole Lord of Lord thing I know so you
said that I just made a false point with
the pluralization of most high no I used
it correctly because in the context you
have the son of man and you have the the
the Ancient of Days who are all sitting
on their throne and they not the same
Throne though right correct they have
they have different Thrones that they
next to the father but my question is my
question is she need to get in
class when you say they got separate
Thrones if they got separate Thrones
then they not the same they're not they
don't have the they're not sitting on
the same Throne no nobody saying saying
that the son is the father there is a
dis saying Jesus Is God let me land let
me land what I'm saying is is that when
I say Jesus Jesus is look this is what
and this and this is how that's how we
know that y'all slow man because look at
using my [__]
again I got you man I got to I got to I
got a pull from the gra yeah you using
it again I got to pull from the gra look
I'm tell this how we know y'all slow
when you you you talk to Christians all
the time the trinitarian Christians all
the time they tell you we believe in one
God one God who exists as three distinct
person that's not in the Bible it is in
the Bible okay so this and this is this
is what we talking about today yeah this
what we talk cuz that's not the verse
and we think we was going to use the
whole hour yeah I know so you asked me
the verse about who uh who's the Lord of
lords in heaven yeah I just yeah I just
wanted your reference um I think it's
and the reason why I ask that is because
um on Earth the mo uh Christ is going to
have those titles so I wouldn't argue
that on Earth yeah but in heaven I'm
talking about the Lord of lords in right
so you
got I believe ain't nobody help me
everybody helping give him the vers give
he need help now if I said everybody
shut up y'all would think I was going
crazy ain't nobody on my side yelled out
versus let me battle so you got I don't
mind the ad libs though so you got
Deuteronomy 10:17
okay Deuteronomy 10:17 it says that
Yahweh is God of gods and Lord of lords
right but now now take me where you
going to bring this to Christ well I'm
just I just want to affirm that he's the
Lord of lords in heaven where you going
to bring me to about Christ I'm I'm I'm
you asking for the recipe already I'm no
no I thought you was bringing me no I
thought you was bringing me to one verse
and then taking me to the verse that
you're actually going to ask me the
question about that's all yes this is my
question to you you affirm that that the
most high that God right Yahweh is you
know the Lord of lords in heaven okay so
then if he's the Lord of lords in heaven
can you get any higher than that
anything higher than the father can get
any higher than the Lord of lords in
heaven nobody can be higher than the
father my specific question is can you
get higher than being the Lord of lords
in heaven the reason why I'm answering
it that way is because anybody can have
a title of being the Lord in heaven just
like 1 Corinthians 8:5 says though there
be many that be called Gods where
whether in heaven or in Earth so I'm not
taken away from anybody can have a title
Christ was called God and he was the
first chapter but who's the Lord of
lords in heaven the father is the Lord
of all but can someone else have a title
of being the Lord yes we just read it in
1 Corinthians 8 and6 so that's why I'm
asking you to just give me the scripture
that you're talking about we ain't got
much time I know cuz you're trying to
stall you're trying to stall I wasn't
stall I'm asking for the scripture you
stall I gave you the scripture you gave
me Daniel 10 10 you gave me Deuteronomy
107 can you be identified as the Lord of
lords in heaven you can be he's
identified as the Lord right now based
on First Corinthians is he the Lord of
lords in heaven you would have to tell
me what you're talking about the
question is is Jesus the Lord of lords
in heaven can I get a scripture
reference the scripture reference is
Deuteronomy 10 ver that's not talking
about Christ thank you so the question
right now is is J so show me the
scripture that you're talking about in
reference to Christ not answer my
question I did answer your qu you the
only scripture you gave so far was
Deuteronomy 10:17 I'm saying that's not
talking about Christ so if you're
telling me that Christ has this title
take me to the verse so who is it
talking about it's talking about the
most high okay so it's talking about the
most high he's the Lord of lords in
heaven okay so you see but the verse
says for the Lord your God is God of
gods and the Lord of lords a great God a
mighty and terrible with regarded not
the person nor taketh the reward that's
what in context the text says so now can
you take me to verse that I don't know
why we got to pull te we already passed
the time it's okay yeah so if you go to
Revelation thank you right you go to
Revelation you see that Jesus
you see that Jesus is called the King of
Kings and the Lord of Lord Revelations
what um Revelation you got uh
19 19 and what uh 11 to
16 11 through 16 yeah if you want to
just here you got you got Revelation
1714 so now this so crazy y this is
crazy so it says and I saw heaven open
and behold a white horse and he that sat
him that sat upon it was called faithful
and true so now he's called that right
so he's called faithful and true that's
the name that's right that's right and
in righteousness he that judge and make
war his eyes were as a flame of fire and
on his head were many crowns and he had
a name written that no man knew but he
himself right yeah so he don't have a
name we know right or it talk about
something different keep going I'm I'm
going to keep going I know
this trying to dog walk you and he was
clothed with the vesture dipped in Blood
and his name is called the word of God
so everybody to pay attention vers 11
he's called two names ver verse 12 he
has no name verse 13
verse verse says he has a name that no
excuse me let's let's be honest with the
text verse 11 says he has two names
faithful and true verse 12 says he has a
name written that no man knew so nobody
knows his name in verse
12 keep on keep on he don't got no name
nobody know the name this name
specifically I understand they hurt they
no you playing man verse 12 say he ain't
got no name we don't know the name let
me say it better so y'all don't get back
in verse 12 he has a name that we don't
know even though verse 11 says his name
is faithful and true nobody's going to
say that's his real name though
important to the listener that's not his
literal name so everybody can pay
attention verse 13 and he was cloth I'm
sorry yeah no I didn't read that and he
was clothed with the vesture dipped in
Blood and his name is called the word of
God now he got three names faithful True
Word of God and then he got a name
nobody knows yeah yeah then we going to
go to 14 and the armies which were in
heaven followed him upon white horses
clothed and linen white and clean and
out of his mouth go off a sharp sword
and just for the record I'm only reading
all these verses because he said all
these verses verse 15 and out of his
mouth goeth a sharp sword that with it
he should Smite the Nations and he
should rule with them with the rod of
iron and tread the wine press and the
fierceness and Wrath of almighty God so
now 15 is saying he's coming with the
Wrath of the almighty God he's not God
he's coming with the wrath of God wow
and on his vesture and on his thigh a
name written King of Kings Lord of lords
now how does that mean
now I'm glad I ain't in Christianity
that's terrible I tell it means break
now now go ahead break it down yeah so
so you so you acknowledge that the Lord
of lords in heaven was the most high
and and the first the verse starts off
with and I saw Heavens open and this
person that he sees not only is the
faithful and true one but he's also the
word of God and he's the king of kings
and Lord of lords in heaven that's not
what it's saying it that's exactly what
it's saying that's not that's not what
it's saying exactly what it's saying
come on clap it up that's not what it's
saying let's get two minutes here let's
get two minutes closing statements cuz
y'all already over hour can I just take
15 seconds okay 15 seconds to minute
closing St that didn't say that he was
that in heaven yes it gave him many
names it gave him the name faithful and
true then it says it has a name written
that no man knew so if no man knows his
actual name how are you going to say
because he has on His Garment Lord of
Lord and king of kings that that now
means that's his name it said on his
vesture is the name it doesn't say that
is his
name it doesn't show me where it says
that's his name all right two minute
closing statements two minute closing
statements we're over an hour we're over
an
hour tar logic went logic went first the
last one you want to go first for the
two minutes and then he'll go last are
we oh okay two minute closings but we
got another we got another round after
this a break yeah debate though two
minutes okay no sweat uh this is light
work um I do like logic good this is
light work once on the subject of Jesus
being God once you establish that Jesus
has a god once he says he has a god once
he has a head that's a god
once you got two Thrones one belong to
Christ One belongs to God you can't now
say Jesus is God and there's no verse in
there that says there's this three this
godhead of a father Son and Holy Spirit
and if there is he didn't demonstrate
that here but we clearly demonstrated as
that the father gave something to the
son we show that the father excuse me
that Christ didn't want to follow excuse
me one of his own will to not take the
cup but then took the cup cuz he obeyed
the father we saw the heavens open up
and said this is my beloved Son and whom
I well pleased so if you have a son and
a father that cannot be the same I year
with that
okay real [__] University by the
way two minutes start now all right so
yeah I appreciate cap for this man this
is fun yeah it's dope it's dope so guys
I I hope that we saw what the problem
was the miscommunication was
subordination versus nature cap was
arguing subordination I was arguing
divine nature and I tried to you know
have him catch up with me but you know
he's a little too slow for that one but
um but but but in regards to that what
we showed was is that Jesus is the
creator of all things and that through
him nothing was made that has been made
and so he himself can't be created or
else he would have to create himself
which we couldn't get an answer to that
on today um now he asked me you know I'm
going use my random man in time he said
show me where that's this name right so
I'll read it again so this is revelation
19:16 it says on his robe and on his
thigh he has a name written what's the
name cap here it is king of kings and
Lord of lords now where is this
happening he says I see Heaven open up
and he saw him who was on the White
Horse coming with the wrath of God
Almighty and he says his name is the
King of Kings and the Lord of lords
earlier he said that the most high is
the Lord of lords so we see that Jesus
if he's the Lord of lords then he is the
most there it is the debate over man
going
oh my God logic
[Music]